[Music]
is
[Music]
so you probably know that wikipedia is
the number one research tool portal in
the world with over 18 billion views uh
a month
but what if everything you thought you
knew about wikipedia
was um
was wrong
i bet it is
[Applause]
his channel has quote some of the most
overt racism of any of the shows i've
ever looked at
[Music]
[Applause]
you
by the power of crowder shop
i have the powers
dave you're not wearing pants tis true
where'd dave get those cool threads
wouldn't you like to know
it's a mystery but you can start your
treasure hunt at crowdershop.com
i think you'll be pleasantly surprised
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to louder
with crowder with dave
yeah good morning everybody uh stephen
is not here he is out yeah i believe he
said uh meatloaf's awake
and uh what we can do
we're excited we already pulled off uh
live show today obviously monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern remember if
rebooted from youtube the show goes on
rumble podcasts mug club mug club you
can watch them anywhere you want right
there
see that rumble nice point yeah it's
good it's good yeah you pointed right at
it that was that was very it was pretty
good yeah you practiced that i'm getting
a little better thank you i was up all
night mate sure that point was good
so i'm excited also today we got a lot
of interesting stuff on the show what
would you do if you were driving down
the highway and saw a crate of monkeys
just scattered just crates all over the
road comment below let us know what you
would do to stop or help or hurt or not
whatever you do touch as many as
possible yeah i would look like dustin
hoffman i would too
i would be like have you guys seen the
matt leblanc movie where one of you play
baseball
and then one would be biting me
so we're very excited to be here don't
forget to go to the merch store um mug
club live slash live chat uh that's in
the merch store maybe i don't know so
you got loud with crowder merch store
you get all kinds you get mugs you can
make it sure if you subscribe you get
the mugs and you get to get to buy the
merch yeah school like best dad ever you
know yeah on a hoist shirt really is the
best one you can get but now on a shark
channel
[Music]
we'll be taking your live chat yeah yeah
you'll be taking your live chat in mug
club yes that was the slash
live chat oh is that what it was well
maybe tell me well hey how about this
dave you're you're going to be in a
couple of places coming up march 26th
and april 9th what do you what do you
think that's right because you sold out
cuyahoga falls
either way it sold out and then denver's
getting close to that for the first week
of february but i will be in march 26th
the victory theater in evansville
indiana
and april 9th the genesee theater
the genesee genesee not hennessy
different theater we got in trouble for
that genesee theater in waukegan
illinois beautiful city yes fantastic i
believe waukegan is the chicago
of the north
with kagan
where is this city we're talking about
lower chicago
lower chicago waukegan yeah
vacation three or four times yeah easy
right it's a nice place to go what the
hell are you guys talking about you've
never been to waukegan no where is it
it's a resort town outside of chicago i
think you're full of crap yeah i think i
am too yeah what do you what is it gary
indiana yeah we go to resort town yeah
you get to actually go to the where the
jackson 5 came from and you can see the
blood spatter from where joe would hit
his kids
so
you'll be better at music for this i
need you to dance and sink
[Laughter]
come here tito you're the weakest
all right
pfizer's got a new vaccine pfizer has i
don't know if you heard started clinical
trials on a new vaccine to combat
the omnicorp virus
uh it's uh it's the variant yay
and i uh uh i do trust them yeah let's
be right who wouldn't right at this
point we got laying the brain here i
didn't even interview everybody yeah did
i blame the brain a little discouraging
but
we're going to go back yeah we'll go
back geralde is here how are you sir i'm
great how about you i am doing
fantastically well i'm a little miffed
at the loser of our last debate that we
allowed him back in the studio but i
don't know about whatever that doesn't
sound right
i gotta say it was it was close guys
was it he made some good it was close
lane won um what
uh also
we got token now and how are you doing
ahoy ahoy there we go and ahoy to you
all at home and we got keegan
he he has no mic
i just wanted to include you we did that
we did that on purpose dave you know why
well the last time is it the sunglasses
those are cool glasses i like them he'll
sit in your chair again
well
that'll be a beating
that other people do for me because i am
a frail old man
and also tim the tool man one of my
favorite people how are you doing today
baby good how are you great we got
laying the brain you want to say oh
there you go so here we go the hell was
that what it's my new catch phrase ah he
says say hello i go ahoy
and you go what that's exactly what just
happened yes
just
do that that's how we do it it's how we
roll guys
let's get on this it's fantastic all
right so we do have pfizer's new vaccine
as we talked about and i think it's
important that we show that the uh
what do you call the the vaccines and
the several boosters have helped many
people there's no doubt about that
across the room we talk about it every
day and there's no reason to not trust
big pharma
yes they may have used heroin and cough
syrup for babies at some point well yes
cocaine may have been used for cough
syrup and babies at some point but we do
know that the opioid epidemic is
somewhat in control because we don't
hear about it anymore nobody dies from
that no nobody and it's not as addictive
as it used to be i've read
red you're right yeah i don't know
the libraries and the books no no well i
didn't read it the guy who sold them to
me told me that so what i have here is
our brand new sponsor
uh opioids we'd like to thank big pharma
for coming out to the show and
sponsoring us with opioids very popular
in the upper midwest after i blew up my
knee playing high school football i
never thought i'd live pain free ever
again
giving birth to triplets and injuring my
back getting rear-ended by a drunk
driver i figured soreness and irritation
were just a part of life
i just needed to escape the daily hell
that i call life
oh
and i had some minor foot pain
i think that's the guy that rear-ended
me
yeah
it is
after my fourth dui i was court ordered
to never drink again and now i have a
scram tether that monitors my alcohol
intake 24 7.
but then my doctor told me about opioids
he said they'd take my pain away for
good
and now i don't suffer because i got a
bottle of 60 warm hugs from god
now that i don't have any pain i can
catch anything that life throws at me
i don't hurt anymore and now my three
kids have a hard time keeping up with me
when i run out of my medicine the agony
returns and then i have to do pretty
sinful things to get more
[Music]
there's only supposed to be one of you
guys
[Music]
my doctor said i'm too pretty to get
addicted
opioids should only be used as medically
prescribed they may cause nausea
headache constipation anal discharge
crocodile tears addiction cult leading
hair lips suicide homicide clowning
around with the fellas and in rare but
fairly often cases death
ask your doctor about opioids today
opioids
because you're not on heroin
yet
opioids get them prescribed for anything
from knee pain to depression available
at your local pharmacy
or doctor who has a loose script pad
i'm glad we have creative control for
all of our sponsors i well i just think
it's important that uh you know they get
back out there in the public big opioids
been really good to work with though
they really have been they've been cool
i like the sample packs they give me the
strawberry yeah
i really do like the strawberry you know
what they call you dave a frequent flyer
that's true okay i like that they tell
you what which opioids to take they're
like these ones are for driving these
ones
we should be
yeah we're good i mean it's a sponsor
it's a sponsor it's not my opinion we're
just trying to say how great big pharma
is well yeah vaccines they've done good
things
[Laughter]
come on now
share it uh you guys remember cher yeah
no if you're gonna turn back time you
might
what
you remember cher wow dave's got the
best jokes do you watch uh
the movie mermaids i didn't yeah i
watched the little mermaid one time is
seen that she's not in there no no she's
you're ugly
she's farther more attractive but uh i
mean cher is 75 years young and says
she's looking good and finally ready to
share her fitness regimen with the world
so here is a clip from her new workout
video
oh my gosh that's almost as good as
sonny bono's ski tutorials yeah that's a
good one that's how i learned to do it
or chase bono's how to make a penis out
of ass fat ah that is a great video no
that was possible did you know that my
home collection yeah it's pretty good i
mean
i added it to my watch list i'll get
there they're all on tape i got the hard
copy yeah oh really i have a soft one
um
in related news geez actress sarah
jessica parker you know her yeah sjp uh
she's also because she's getting a
little older but still good looking so
she's also decided to put out an
exercise program as well
[Music]
[Applause]
clip-clop into the oldies that's what it
is
i believe she's on what's called a
gallopon
[Music]
i don't know that 1-800 number was still
available man that's uh i got to tell
you
i think you can what's funny is i guess
mr big on the new uh sex and the city
dies on a peloton does he yeah like the
first episode you know why right
because he got me tooed he did he got
notified and they're like all right
we're gonna kill you on a peloton why
would you go back to the show though
where they're like you're me too but now
we're gonna murder you and it's like
that's cool i'll come admit guilt yeah
that's your penance how do you die on a
peloton uh he had a heart attack ah well
that's good well what happened was he
took a bunch of our sponsors
not our other sponsor next to that no no
no no he was on our opioid sponsor
mixed with our fentanyl sponsor which
we'll be on later this week
it's called fentanyl we're not that bad
well i kill you a little no it's
fentanyl for elephants it's not your
fault if you take it
we all know sarah is uh married to
matthew broderick
and uh because he wants to jump on the
same bandwagon he is
uh now putting out an educational series
oh good for him it teaches driver's
education
jeez was that him no no he killed a guy
in ireland what yeah with this car is
that real i think a couple
really yeah yeah yeah but he got off
because he was in you know ferris
bueller's day off and they were like
sometimes
what do you say porsche sometimes you
got to kill nothing less or whatever you
got to kill people like joyce it was an
accident i mean if you put the steering
wheel on the right side those people
would still be alive today
but he's not wrong no what are you
laughing at that's correct that's
correct if he was driving in the right
lane i mean the irish guy in his own
country and matthew broderick was
driving in the right lane whatever you
get it he's just he really killed two
people he yeah he crashed head-on and i
guess his car had airbags ah and there i
guess then it's not his fault there's
our head of windshield
didn't laura bush kill somebody
yeah wow
laura bush is a guy with a car and uh
long prison term for that yeah yeah big
oh wait no not at all and well and i
actually prefer bruce jenner's crash
course whatever happened to uh to him uh
oh oh wait a minute
he killed killed someone and then became
a woman woman right i forgot that he
doubt fired his way out of that one
classic american tail you know just
whatever you do is you if you kill
someone with a car pretend uh you're
your sister
so
ah get some stuff i think i've got some
hunger pains man like you have been
looking hungry yeah i am why you told
you earlier my stomach was grumbling i
didn't know if you know we have actually
as a sponsor that is delicious and i
like them way more than opioids is built
bar yes have you had my favorite i gotta
say
i like the mint chocolate i like the
coconut which double chocolate
i noticed you're holding up one of the
very best
one of the very best flavors ever the
birthday lane
the birthday cake is the best
really good i taste tested every single
one at least five times oh wow and then
you put them back that's the weird part
well i didn't wanna eat the whole thing
he likes to share gerald that's not what
i heard sharing is caring
you know a lot of people like to share
build bars even if you're brothers
how you doing i'm pandemic stopper and
grandma savior andrew cuomo and this is
my brother chris
just don't call me fredo
[Laughter]
and we're here today to tell you why we
like built boss
it's because
why do we love them so much chris
because they don't ask for consent hey
you can eat them you can lick them
and you can suck them
in
there
and you can talk dirty to him
i'm gonna bust you in half you're gonna
need a wheelchair to get around for the
next three weeks
yeah
[Music]
you know what's good about these what's
good about them
you can't undress them damn yeah you
don't even have to ask
i usually gotta get three nose before
that period i just come through
a little bit of spaghetti
yeah that's all right you spit on it you
like that i like to get spit on
and the best part is they're sugar-free
which means they're built without the
guilt
where you been all my life
[Music]
don't tell my wife
oh yeah oh you got a sister hey andrew
oh yeah
i don't think they're sugar-free they're
not sugar-free no but they're for
brothers are idiots they're low sugar
very low very low sugar they're not the
best spokespeople for it they're
guilt-free and well they're guilt-free
because they won't tell on you for
sexually assaulting them but by the way
i just got a call yeah built bar wants
uh they want creative control back oh do
they really that's strange i thought
it's weird because i think i think that
sold them more
well well you know what i think i think
bill barr is delicious uh and i honestly
i think you should try them go to
buildbar.com and use promo code
crowder15 capital c
to get 15 off your next order i assure
you you're gonna enjoy them especially
for those who work out i'm told well and
let us know too a lot of people have uh
like screenshotted their order for the
first time and then send a tweet or
instagram or facebook or a myspace or a
yelp
something you know yeah you can yelp
yeah why don't you link in us what you
think
of yours
i was trying to think of like older ones
that i could throw in there they got
that yahoo messengered me yeah you can
do that
make sure they tell us their favorite
flavors so we can settle this debate we
can we're going to do a poll that's what
we're going to do i'm with i agree i
agree laying the brains got a point oh
jeez again really you still look hungry
though which is like bud i i kind of am
i mean i've got some pickles over here
pickles yeah do you think i should try
that like i hear the pic the i don't
know why you have pickles but are they
good that's fantastic actually are they
really i like pickles a lot
i didn't know he was such a pickle fan
i saw spickle i saw him like eating the
pickles out there yeah but i didn't know
that he was like die hard
outside of the office too or just
jar right here giant that's a lot of
pickles there's a lot well i like
pickles i i there's nothing wrong with
liking pickles right there's nothing it
doesn't make you a bad person to like
hey fine then what's the big deal i like
pickles i might need a pickle on there
have a pickle okay i will i just we are
inclusive we like kind of like touch the
salt off though i'm not gonna like brian
stelter the pickle but i'm gonna eat the
pickle
nothing intended by this that's between
you and selter and the devil just so you
know we everybody's
brian stellar is good at his job how
many screenshots of eating a pickle
yeah what does it enjoy the pickle
you seem to like it a lot it's good how
would you describe the flavor good
picklish
but like good pickles
it's it's a great pick like if you were
gonna sell this pickle would you say
it's it's good easy to swallow
i'm not gonna do this
yeah like is it a handful
easy to eat just eat your pickle you
weirdo
all right i felt like the best thing to
do was to shut up did you why why did
you hear about this monkey crash i did
hear about the monkey crash yes
are you a fan of monkeys i'm more of an
ape dude but yeah monkeys aren't bad the
friends monkey pretty cool guys friends
monkey's cool dude i agree you like
monkeys you're more of an ape dude
well he like you know can we explore
that a little
gorilla's awesome in the middle okay
yeah simon
the
yes the congo
i think it's congo it should be called
the congo that's that's how old people
talk like i was watching the congo yeah
or anytime they're watching i posted
about it on the facebook yeah i'm trying
to watch my stories that's one
just watching my story grandma's stories
people that don't have jobs that stay
home yeah these of our lives if you use
the term my stories chances are you're
gonna are you gonna die in an old folks
home of covid soon uh in new york
watching my stories everything hurts
those places
uh old folks homes yeah a lot of sex did
you know that i heard that it's like
high school yeah it just you got viagra
to keep the guys from rolling out of
beds it's like a kickstand but then
they're like well i gotta touch
something with this isn't that crazy
just is that what they smell so weird it
probably is yeah sucks no it's also it's
also why there's plastic on all the
furniture
you thought it was the other reason it's
not it's not dust in the air it's just
what's left
what if you did you remember the show
room raiders on mtv yeah what if you
room rated like an old photo
and there's like slow motion sloths
banging pretty much just heart attacks
trying to bring up the black light
for ethel
i'm falling
my nana was a job my nan was an old
folks home i loved her but it was one of
those places where it's like you just
had to keep telling her how much she
liked it
and so she believed it would repeat it
no i like it here it's wonderful the
beatings are fantastic yes the the [ __ ]
gang member only punches me for dinner
every other orderly has been stiller
from
will put you to sleep
oh your fingers hurt now you pulled
lances
now your back's gonna hurt
all monkeys
are now accounted for in the crash by
the way oh thank goodness man
uh crates of monkeys were scattered
across route 54 um following the crash
and enough people saw this
uh just all those crates
that's
[Laughter]
how else is amazon prime supposed to
deliver them dave
they were just all over train tracks in
los angeles we don't want this thing
cheese
why are they in boxes yet
here's your sex monkey all right so
sign here here
they're like bananas all right so um
the crates were scattered all over the
place of the 100 monkeys on board
three initially escaped
luckily thanks to our brave first
responders the final monkey was captured
oh we actually have footage of the
incidents
that's ross geller's monkey
it definitely is a friend that's your
monkey that's
wait matt leblanc was in a movie with
the monkey well he was in friends with
ross's yeah he was in well
the movie i think was called joe it was
him in an ape that plays baseball oh not
to be confused with any one of the
golden retriever movies such as the
golden receiver
the ape that plays baseball there's
actually two golden receivers one is not
legal yeah um oh boy what
oh what is more concern
that was the ross that was the friends
monkey
monkey you're one i don't want to say
they all look the same but the kind
animals kind of do like penguins it's
like i don't know well like if i met one
penguin i'd be like i just met that guy
wouldn't you say though that the three
monkeys that survived a car accident and
escaped their boxes were like yeah you
get to go yeah it's like you're free
like oh thank god we got them back no
the three monkeys were living free lives
it should be like the fugitive yeah but
these were lab monkeys well it doesn't
matter i mean well they've been
they've been infected with aids but
other than that
yeah that's
it is a prison bus tipping over like
maybe they should be on a con air monkey
plane
tommy lee jones is on the way yeah he's
like
i gotta find him
come on doctor every head house monkey
house dog house dr monkey kimmel
uh what
[Laughter]
dr john monkey kimball oh man what is
more concerning though is a woman
stopped to help the truck driver and
ended up touching
one of the what what is that word cox
mccox
is that real
yes that she stopped and touched my cox
even first name philip even where she
forgot her phone
uh posting on facebook
so i was behind a truck who had 100
monkeys and was hit by a dumpster truck
four monkeys escaped one guy had to go
to the hospital and i forgot my cell
phone
oh that's a good leader it's so sad
very descriptive we need a picture to
prove it liar
wow what an idiot all right so
uh the woman apparently thought the
monkeys were
cats
eyewitness news spoke with a woman who
witnessed the unusual story unfold right
in front of her eyes
they had this like green cloth over so i
pull up back and i go to stick my finger
in there to try to pet it and it pops
his head up and i'm like oh it's a
monkey so i was like i'm shocked so i
walked over to the guy and i'm like
they're not cats they're monkeys because
they're what i'm like they're monkeys
yeah that makes sense you're trying to
jam your finger in the cast
i went over to finger a cat and it was a
monkey i didn't know monkeys monkey if
you were to imagine a lady that would
stick her finger in a monkey cage would
it come up any different than exactly
what she is
yeah she definitely looks like a woman
who would try to stick her finger in a
monkey cage
[Applause]
it turned out to be going oh
and i thought about it and i remembered
that's not meow
what a dance all right so
he's like yes it says monkey on the box
ma'am
right here big letters i have never
looked at a cat in my life and said is
that a monkey
i think it's a spider monkey i can't
tell either that or garfield oh it threw
feces at me never mind oh yeah i know
what it is you're a pet a monkey or a
hat
an ape an agent yeah chimpanzee again
i'm telling you apes rule yeah have you
ever had a monster uh i don't think so
that's weird
what spank one why is that weird no
why is it weird you don't go to monkey
petting zoos
i used to be really good those pickles
do look like they get a little further
away from the mic because of those
you're crunching on those bad boys
i like the you can hear the crunch and
the slurpee they're good they're good
pickles i mean i usually don't eat
pickles but if i was good why not i
don't know pickles are great stop it all
right well i just don't usually eat them
alone like you do
i don't mean like just i mean just the
pickle not like you're alone at home
eating pickles crying
crying as i eat my pickles dave
well some people i told you that in
confidence i cry when i eat anything
mainly ice cream
when i just think when's my prom date
coming
i guess never so
sadly our oh
three monkeys in the story did have to
be euthanized
you missed you missed an important thing
oh yeah yeah oh did she oh i forgot
let's go back
well she ended up having to go to the
emergency room after developing pink eye
and a cough from fingering the monkey
pink guy in a cough
that's not gonna be pink eye in a cough
that's ebola she's like oh that was the
monkey's butt i just stuck my finger in
i really believe that oh geez now i got
the pink eye all over again
every time oh she got the monkey pox
variant
oh my lord she's gotta have something
terrible right
no no no no it's not quite as bad as uh
the omnicron is it not are they gonna
let her in and be like look we know
you're petting monkeys you look very
sick but you know no we're just going to
put her with other old people that have
also yeah shoved their face in monkeys
yeah and just see what happens just to
ensure yeah the best outcome hey guys i
have pink eye don't you want it too yeah
come on i got eyes at itch i thought
them was cats my butt itches wait she's
from pennsylvania why does she sound
like this she's an idiot i don't know i
mean no no she does i mean it's a good
accent i just yeah well yeah
they're monkeys i feel like she told the
driver that i'm like i think he knows
she looks like alice cooper after he
died
drowning in a tub
she got that mitch mcconnell
where she was like i was petting the
monkeys
and now my eyes burn those are not cats
i got a brain fish there's a rash where
i put my finger in
i shouldn't be always petting stuff
before i know what it is
[Laughter]
why would there be a truckload of cats
why would there be little monkeys
that makes more sense to me
we do research on those what does this
thing go into petsmart or something well
we do research on monkeys but why are
they just driving through pennsylvania
is there a big testing facility it's a
common misconception they weren't
driving somebody else oh my bad
i thought matt leblanc was in shotgun
that's why it crashed you got a monkey
driving no it was bill murray don't
drive angry all right
that's a great nicholas cage movie it
really is yeah monkeys
monkey eyes nicholas cage
monkeys
on a plane
criminal monkeys i would love to watch
uh nicholas cage movies where he just
kills monkeys and you don't even know
why
you're like they're not even bad it's
like just in a zoo were they on their
way to like revlon or clinique to get
yes
just to get lipstick put on them
it's been amazing for years we were like
let's put lipstick on monkey's lips and
then they're like oh they're burning the
monkey ah like why would you test makeup
like that i thought they just screeched
like that for fun like to communicate
it's just weird what we've done to
animals well better us or better than us
sorry it's why i don't eat meat
that's not true at all i know i eat meat
all the time yes you do i just like dogs
if you're not a dog i'll eat you
anyway wait what
you like
that no i don't get it i need them i
think i think we should probably move on
from you you would need a monkey being
eaten
you would never eat a monkey a dinosaur
you didn't try him he's more of a pickle
guy
gerald does love pickles i do love
pickles so we do want to go all right
we'll move on sorry fine i didn't mean
to derail everything by talking about
that i like to eat meat
sadly
three monkeys did have to be put down
they were euthanized uh two had dirt on
the clintons like i said and the third
one
went bananas and shot himself thank you
thank you
best joke ever oh my oh thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
fastest man on his feet that's right
that is the best joke ever award which
is a
a smooth man a naked man with no bullets
of gold
the best joke ever award best dude your
desk is getting kind of crowded
it really is it really is i have i have
a lot of stuff it's like i don't know
what i want to put in my mouth first
the bars the gun
the guy
this is a busy nest
i got pipes over here
you got several mugs going on you got
stuff to write with though i'm not sure
you're using i do like these you have
you have mugs of water and yet you have
a bottle of water on your desk
water is not a sponsor today
water's not a sponsor no pickles is the
sponsor pickles it's big pickle man well
you're the one that brought it in loving
these pickles i don't know what it's all
about
i'm gonna pickle
nothing wrong with that
delayed slurp ahoy um
but uh about an hour look we're not
gonna get off this monkey topic because
it's important
fauci likes his monkeys speaking of
monkeys
did you know that morgan island not my
island
no not your old morgan
gerald
did you know the gerald morgan
island no
carolina
has been nicknamed monkey island because
it's
full of monkeys oh my god it just makes
common sense
[Laughter]
all the monkeys on the island are owned
by the nih
and are subjected to fauci experiments
animals and animal experiments are not
right or left this is an issue that can
bring both sides of the aisle together
morgan island also known locally as
monkey island growing up in south
carolina's low country we always thought
this was a retirement home or sanctuary
for primates or monkeys that have been
using experiments we'll come to find out
after white coat waste did a foia
request and gather documentation
they are taking approximately 600
primates and monkeys and using them on
scientific gruesome and barbaric
experiments much like the puppies that
by the way dr fauci never responded to
our letter about the beagle puppies so
uh i might have to rename this island
from monkey island to fauci island just
to get a response on these things um
it's crazy it's barbaric it's gruesome
and it's gotta end
gosh shauchi also made a different group
of lab monkeys uh trans and gave them
aids you know for science for science we
did not it's right on the website of
what nih funds they take male monkeys
they put them in metal boxes that's
where they're forced to live they
subject them to hormone so-called
hormone treatment and from that they're
supposed to learn something about hiv
transmission now never mind that monkeys
don't actually contract hiv they don't
actually develop aids
this is a study that could be done with
human volunteers and we might actually
find something out that would help human
beings hmm wow that's strange because
they i thought that monkey did have aids
because he was offered a new sitcom on
cbs two and a half monkeys
he was also offered a spot on cnn okay
what i was referring to he's taking over
cuomo's old spot yeah is that what he's
doing okay i thought it was something
about that co-hosting with brian stelter
yeah brian steltzer though i i i know is
not uh
well you know i don't a monkey so he's
not 100
hetero if i depend on one of those two
things it's not a monkey so uh let's
talk about some movies you guys like
movies i do like love them watched them
before do you have you seen them see
movies is movies a sponsor no movies is
not a sponsor but i enjoy talking a
little pop culture there we go little
pop culture right that's right big guy
best joke ever trophies on your desk not
mine oh sorry my bad it's going in my
bathroom
what happened
so
china edited fight club i don't know if
you guys saw this chinese streaming
platform
uh tencent video has released fight club
but gave it a slightly different ending
instead of tyler durden killing his
alter ego china's version ends like this
you shot yourself yes but it's okay
marla look at me
i'm really okay
trust me
everything's gonna be fine
[Music]
through the clue provided by tyler the
police rapidly figured out the whole
plan and arrested all criminals
successfully preventing the bomb from
exploding after the trial tyler was
sentenced to a lunatic asylum receiving
psychological treatment he was
discharged from treatment in 2012.
it's a hundred percent real hey guys
yeah this isn't by the way we didn't do
that
yeah this is not a sp so you see the
editing it's like okay what was the
bright flash in the background of the
building across the way exploding then
like come on guys cut it before
well
that's the part that i love the giant
bomb going off in the back they pause it
they're like that's when the cops come
in
and they stop the bomb from exploding
yes even that one in the midst of
exploding
[Laughter]
like watching the second tower go down
and they're like that's when they
stopped al qaeda
so we have in this
and this isn't even the first time china
has revised hollywood as we know they've
done a lot of stuff like in the new top
gun movie mavericks bomber jacket was
changed to remove the taiwanese and
japanese flags ah because taiwan doesn't
exist that's correct we know why they
did that to japan uh and in the
oscar-winning
bohemian rhapsody
uh freddy's mercury
not gay what really yeah how did they
edit the entire movie out they did uh
it's actually
it's eight minutes long
and it's called freddy didn't get
fingered
oh god
there's they but they did they deleted
the scene where he kissed his boyfriend
they cut out uh up close uh a close-up
of freddy's crotch they deleted the
first scene where freddie's girlfriend
tells me it's gay it's okay actually the
word gay isn't allowed anywhere in the
movie happy and they cut out the scene
where freddie dresses as a woman to film
i want to break free
so what it is is actually
it like i said it's a few minutes long
it's just wimbledon where he's doing the
least effeminate dancing
it's just remy malek sitting there doing
yeah
right we're like where he's not like
making love to a microphone basically
they actually just show the bassist
[Laughter]
count him as the singer well and the
prom does persist today like this is a
real thing like china does change a lot
of their movies because they're a major
box office and a lot of times america
gets blamed for this this racism which
is actually not us at all well before we
look at this you got to understand why
like last year china actually overtook
north america as the biggest box office
in the world so you got to do what you
got to do to get the movies in there
because they have like a cap on movies
no you don't i i don't agree with it but
but it is a fact also the finance movies
they they uh they finance them through
foreign sales oh yeah they they sell the
movie in foreign markets before they
even start making it oh absolutely and
tons of the studios are like co-financed
by chinese i hate companies we all hate
it
but well because we we and i don't hate
that we make movies that work for
different markets i don't mind that i
don't even mind that you make movies for
other markets no big deal there i hate
that you change
the movies around completely in the
country that allowed you to be able to
do this in the first place and kind of
help launch this industry globally in
the first place
to appease other markets but you don't
do stuff for us it's like oh we're gonna
take the taiwan flag and the japanese
flag like i get okay i know you hate
taiwan we've we've known that for a long
time but the japanese flag office jacket
why are you doing that no it's it it
really is crazy it's just sad because it
is they're still a real country right
okay
can we get john cena online make sure
japan's
yeah well john cena does a lot for them
i mean according to him uh uh taiwan not
real no no no no not real at all big
mistake on his part no he apologized
profusely in mandarin he did because and
by the way very broken mandarin but i
was just happy to know that he speaks it
not frightening at all like this is a
guy who used to go and like go to like
hospitals and see children and do good
things and now he's like taiwan's not
real give me money well i think john
cena actually if we translated it he was
just yelling that that that that right
yeah me
yeah and we're not gonna go i'm gonna
say the rest speaking
but gerald like a like maybe a speck of
bright news uh spider-man huge movie
right yes biggest of the it actually
didn't even open in china because
they didn't bow to the censorship and
they still got huge box office numbers
so see
make good movies
yeah it's definitely the biggest movie
the last two or three years but yeah
yeah well
it's it's top three i think it goes star
wars
and then uh avengers end game and then
spider-man yeah because it's it's a good
movie too i went and saw it with my son
what is this
spider-man what no way no way that's
what i thought it's kind of how much i
pay attention to spider-man movies yeah
but it's like all of them coming
together and as a sam raimi fan being
from detroit yeah you know i like the
fact that they they they're all pretty
good yeah
i mean studio messed with spider-man 3
that sam raimi did there's some flaws in
there but they're all decent i didn't
hate them i just thought the uh it's not
like avengers stuff the hulk angley one
or the in bulk any of them or the guy
who plays the hulk and the new one who's
just
what's lovely
ruffalo and i used to love
marcus
i i prefer the one where tyler durden is
hulk i mean yeah
fantastic yeah that one's pretty brad
pitt played the hulk no no the actual
tyler durden at the end not the crazy
part yeah edward norton before he called
the cops yeah yeah yeah yeah yes before
the bomb well that one that one
explosion the superior film oh i mean
it's the first the best i like edward
norton i hear he's not a dick
so
not that i would say that that's what
other people say that's what other
people say but the problem does persist
a persist today it does and i think it's
important they do have some new movies
coming out that i think we should show
uh one is uh not black panther hmm
there's the poster is that john cena
that is john cena he's gonna be the star
uh it's pretty good it's about a guy
who's not black
another movie uh laying the brain if you
want to go ahead and take this one so
they're actually re
releasing les miserables and this time
it tells the true story at the end jean
valjean instead of dying actually wakes
up and he realizes all just a nightmare
and the french revolution never happened
right and don't look on google because
you definitely won't find any searches
of it happening ever
ever in history ever so revolution
revolution bad revelation it doesn't
exist does not exist not a real thing
the figment of your imagination never
think about revolting especially in 1989
right didn't happen no nothing happened
then no
do you have a clip
[Music]
hold on is that real
is that really what they put up totally
are you come on really i mean
[Laughter]
no we wrote that yesterday but
fight club tech club was real fight club
was real okay well yeah fight club was
real this could be real i'm not gonna i
don't know i mean this isn't out of the
realm of possibility i'm pretty sure not
black panther is real like if you watch
i don't know i knew that was i didn't
even ask it just called panther in the
real black panther in china they don't
take his mask off in the poster because
they don't want you to know i know yeah
they leave the mask yeah
no there's there's plenty of uh hate
there i'm just gonna leave that up like
keep guessing guys i know it's panther
and it says black panther and the suit
is black but what is it
it's john cena
it's jet li
i think you should cover this next one
you're a very uh uh christian guy yes
yes so you're probably more offended by
that right right mel gibson wants more
blood in movies and so uh you know they
wanted to be able to release this in
china so it's passion of the confucius
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
heat disrespect father oh you got to put
it back up ah yeah what it says for
audio listeners or you guys for the
audio people that's okay but we'll we'll
just you know what screw it he
disrespect father
he disrespect faza he never come back no
arrive again
no resurrection for you china number one
there were our last chinese fans
i thought that was pretty close the last
christian
in our demographics we had one chinese
one christian and they're gone there's
one
yeah
throwing his laptop out a window
[Laughter]
i mean come on we all have accents yes
chucking out a window and accidentally
killing a monkey
it's like oh and they escaped again ah i
better go down and finger it
uh so the sixth sense pink eye the sixth
sense is my favorite ending that they
changed it is yeah uh let's take a
gander you guys remember that the the m
night shy llama llama ding dong classic
i knew it
what is it why did you leave me
i didn't leave you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i see people
[Music]
we don't know they're dead
[Music]
bruce willis was chinese the whole time
haha tricky
[Music]
i remember that ending like the whole
movie you're like he was chinese the
whole time i knew it from the very
beginning
well we do have to get out here in a
minute but we uh let's see what we got
here we have one more thing i think we
got it well oh
yes indeed the portland pickle accused
of exposing his dickle the portland
pickle recently took over a baseball
team's twitter a new account how
exciting but this time as social media
connoisseur took a turn right after his
first tweet
with the image if you want to go ahead
and show it they wrote new phone
is this why you've been sucking on
pickles the whole show no i just prefer
pickles and i was trusting my wow
co-workers
we had the mascot there and you have
just been sucking on pickles the whole i
don't know
i've actually been covering my face and
eating pickles yeah eating you've been
eating the dickles pickles i think
you've got a different sponsor
difference
i mean we we talked about weird
perversions yesterday so it's kind of
weird that all of a sudden today he
brings in pickles he tells us outside
that as a sponsor i hate everyone
eating definitely isn't a euphemism for
anything no it guys all right so if you
want to you can suck on gerald's dickle
pickles nope they are available at his
wine shop
i don't sell pickles i hate all of you
you don't sell them because you want
them all in your mouth
all right so
do me a favor if you guys like gerald
eating pickles let us know if you feel
that maybe he's repressing something go
ahead and
he's gonna punch me go ahead and comment
comment comments smash these various uh
comments you gon die you're gonna die
all right and remember uh go ahead leave
if you like the uh
we can do more movies about china if you
like me uh come and see my shows i have
a lot of shows coming up yeah i want to
thank you all for tuning in but right
now we're gonna go off to mug club for
our listeners yeah is there anything i'm
forgetting no they get some free uh
little little contents little extra
content yeah they get a little extra and
we get some chat yeah yeah so ladies and
gentlemen uh what do we say
piss off youtube